here's CNN covering Tucker leaving it's
Anderson Cooper and Democrat strategist
Paul the gala and he's uh well this is
this is wonderful analysis I can't
imagine why nobody watches This Crowd
do the remaining hosts at Fox whoever
replaced the soccer Carlson is there any
there's no incentive to tone down their
own rhetoric is there
no they're not going to change I think
right wing media in the last 25 years
has it been all about the Overton window
right what was unacceptable 20 years ago
Tucker didn't say any of those things
when I worked with him at Crossfire is
now mainstream conservative media and
it's only going to get more here's okay
you know what I'd like to see here's how
we'll know that fox has changed they
won't do it fox has changed if they
replace Tucker with an undocumented
Mexican immigrant that would actually
truly be a great replacement
um I can't imagine that Maria Bartiromo
is sleeping well tonight I mean
is that funny
it wasn't funny okay I just had to check
yeah it's not funny uh but putting aside
that it's not funny you know Fox News
even without Tucker is still going to
have better ratings than CNN and
Anderson Cooper and the rest of it right
they still have a bunch of hosts there
that people still love right a certain
set of people still love uh Hannity tons
and tons of people still love Greg
Gutfeld and what's going on over at the
five and all that
um would they tone down the rhetoric Fox
is the only look regard you may be angry
at Fox right now and I think there's
reasons to be angry at Fox for sure
um we will find out the specifics of
some of that and actually what happened
like I don't know for all you know if
Tucker if Tucker beat a woman or
something and that's why he's leaving
then then it's a different situation
there's no reason to believe that you
understand what I'm saying
um but that fox should tone down the
rhetoric is a ridiculous comment from
someone at CNN not only because Fox gets
better ratings but because what he
really means is they should tone down
the rhetoric they should stop fighting
for anything remotely close to
conservative values or for anything
related to the Republican party or
anything else they should just be like
us they should just be like us like
would would CNN ever say MSNBC should
tone down the rhetoric while they're
demonizing the hell out of parents who
want to be involved in their children's
education or whatever they're lying
about desantisan on any given day he
would never say that because left-wing
rhetoric can be as hot as possible but
right-wing rhetoric we should just be
getting beaten and bludgeoned all day
long and just sit there and take it one
of the reasons that the ladies of the
view are so excited that he's leaving
and that that Anderson Cooper is focused
on his rhetoric and the rhetoric of the
network is because he was making a
difference he was making a dent in their
hegemonic control of the media and and I
and mainstream cultures minds and guess
what once again ladies he's going to be
bigger than ever before
[Music]
foreign